good morning John is a Friday and we've
got some different perspectives on
punctuality I get to the airport like a
half hour before the flight takes off I
mean it's Missoula and I'm usually
checked in beforehand anyway and I never
check a bag because I've changed my
pants like once a week that might be too
much information it might be a pro tip
I'm not sure than 10 years of doing it
this way I've never missed a flight I
have however been late for a lot of
things I am a chronically late purse
sometimes I'm just trying to get that
last thing done before I go at the door
or I just totally spaced and forgot the
thing existed and I always underestimate
how long something is going to take I
don't like this about myself I
understand that me showing up late is
seen as a sign of disrespect by people
and it is it is disrespectful I feel
terrible about that because I really
respect the people I work with and I
valued them tremendously but I'm not
showing it this has gotten worse with
the book which has a lot of deadlines
and a lot of meetings and a lot of
signing and signing and signing and
signing and signing yeah and also ever
since Oren was born I've just had to do
a better job of implementing the
strategies that I have developed over
the last 20 years of being someone who
is chronically late and here are seven
of the most important things that I as a
chronically late person do to not be
that person as much one I let people
know what I'm going to be late and I let
them know by how much I'm going to be
late and I do not lie about that if I'm
gonna be 10 minutes late I don't engage
in some sort of miraculous wishful
thinking and think maybe I will get
there in five minutes I'll say I'm gonna
be five minutes late cuz it'll make a
little less bad right in the moment and
then stretch the bad feeling out a
little bit no this is terrible never do
this who think of the thing that's gonna
happen not as the time at which it's
going to happen but as the amount of
time until it's going to happen my
deeply irrational brain sees 11:49 and
11:50 as two very different times but it
understands that 11 minutes from now is
very similar to 10 minutes from now my
phone actually tells me how many minutes
something is away rather than at what
time it will happen 3 if it's gonna take
six minutes to get somewhere I need to
be driving out of the driveway with six
minutes left not standing up from my
desk to go find my computer and wonder
where my keys are and then kiss my baby
goodbye so that I get in the car and the
meeting is already starting all those
things are gonna happen
time I need to plan for them for
multiple alarms I have two alarms that
go off for every event one a half an
hour before the event and one two
minutes before the event this is
especially helpful for things like
conference calls because I don't have to
go anywhere I don't just end it for my
death and about half an hour passes
between when I get reminded and when the
call is I'm gonna be deep researching
salt mining techniques or something by
the time the conference call runs around
into this about myself so I have that
two-minute warning I just get on the
conference call which is maybe number
five sometimes I get on the conference
call five even ten minutes before that
call starts and just listen to that dope
music and do other stuff so that I'm not
late when other people show uh six
here's the thing about myself I like to
not waste time and this is part of the
problem and I feel like if I get
someplace early that will be a waste of
time but I have mentally shifted myself
to realize that if I get someplace early
something interesting and useful is
going to happen at that place in the
same way that it's happening at my desk
if I'm not leaving her and finally
number seven my most important tip every
time you are late get out your little
notes taking app whatever it is and
write down why it happened
diagnose yourself understand yourself
figure this out so that is both advice
and an apology to everyone including you
John I'm sorry that I'm late all the
time I'll see you on Tuesday and yes
signed editions of an absolutely
remarkable thing are going to be a thing
limited numbered not all pre-orders will
be signed but they are currently
available at Amazon Barnes & Noble and
books-a-million they will also be
available at your local bookstore when
the book comes out but only in the US
and Canada that's just how it works I'm
sorry if you already ordered don't worry
the book hasn't shipped yet so you can
very easily go in and cancel it and
order the signed edition which is a
separate thing on those websites there's
links at Hank recom